I am on spider-man in the time it takes
this cat to make a leap of faith named
free dr. doc famous English people maybe
Bobby Brown Little Mix and James Corden
to you morning the time it takes this
pug to week or sorry spam on my lap oh
and the time it takes this dog to pop
his balloon name three things you can't
live without my throne my boy from a
funny guys make it a bit more difficult
for me I'm so good at this I'm like a
deer really goes and the time it takes
this rat to eat a piece of popcorn man 3
it's gonna take it for a violent the
size of the between things please pushes
bra Oh David I'm ready and the limit
takes this dog to climb one step on him
yeah that's well quick name for Dada
Little Mix you can rewards where's
cannonball
charge Max and black magic are they
actually number ones yeah they were and
the time it takes this character shake
off the tee means five delicious foods
so Nero's bangers and mash shepherd's
pie Oh chips and our crumbling customer
so the time it takes this dog to break
the spaghetti twice named three doctor
doc Asian countries Japan Japan Japan
Japan and John and the time it takes
this dog to ascend to the seer then name
for things beginning with T Jade juice
junks Jaguars and the time it takes this
dog to drop you stick him for doctor top
Olympic sports high jump long jump the
timer takes this rain or a break his
twig noon for team sports Newcastle
Liverpool manga night in West Ham you
lost because that's not what it meant
what do you mean football this is what
happens in the time it takes this dog to
lick off the yogurt name traitor
reptiles Oh an iguana a bearded dragon
and Melissa well I Jack and the time it
takes this dog to pop his balloon name
for American TV shows American Dad
Family Guy new girl
that was a really hard one I'm so glad I
didn't get that Oh girls and the time it
takes this dog to make a splash named
for dr. Simpson kind of March Bart Lisa
no and the timer takes us dog the fall
off the edge name three disgusting foods
Pease pudding well rice pudding
saveloy dick and the time it takes this
dog to abandon it stick could be a long
time cool name for da things you find on
o'clock then smelly little things a
bottle of water a tire oh that was hard
a dedication to that stick was appalling
and a timer takes this dog to get in the
pool name five weather types stormy wind
bring sunny I deserved that actually so
I was there I just slipped in nearby
chocolate ice cream yeah
vanilla to stash your personnel
[Music]